test
hello okay that should work
should be gucci
hello everybody
hello hello hello
not a new setup i'm just in my l.a place
right now so
yeah
jeff aquino marcus my skimmer
lily
folklorist what is up everybody
ah don what's up man what's up what's up
george thomas kelly thompson what is up
everybody let me make sure some settings
are okay here
oh gotta switch that
it is switched i think uh mr anderson in
the house
what up what up what up ben pulliam
what's up my dude
uh
i don't know if we're gonna see carol
danvers in this episode you know um
i'm thinking post credits
i really am
jeff thanks for super chat i i really
hope it ends well
as well
shawn
what up what up thank you
scissor edits my shirt looks cool thank
you it's a stray kid's shirt i went to
their concert uh with my friend wendy
over at the movie couple that her and
her husband have her and i uh
and i went to see straight kids sunday
it's today's tuesday
so we went to see it sunday uh it was
awesome they are awesome uh their k-pop
group
uh super awesome like
they rap uh they have great vocals like
they're just they're really cool yeah i
definitely
definitely recommend checking out
straight kids if you guys like good
music
makabel al sagar thanks appreciate that
always nice to hear from fans around the
world love it uh louis barry thank you
super chat hope carol monica matt spidey
gemma's i know you've been saying that
i'm definitely thinking i'm thinking
just carol man unfortunately um
if there's one thing that i think we've
learned from these disney plush shows
is that they really stick they really
like stick to
what the show's about
and don't really have you know all these
huge cameos like we'd like them to have
like like we've been thinking that
there's gonna be so
sadly i think uh
sadly i think um it's just gonna be
carol
hey
sue what's up missed you too
another week we will be doing
live streams even when
there aren't disney plus shows to watch
um they will be during the day not
really late at night
but uh we will we will be doing them
we'll be doing them uh for those asking
this is not a new setup this is i'm
actually at my place in la i have a
place in la now i was here uh
doing some business
um working on some cool stuff
so i'm in my apartment in la right now
that's where we are i don't have my
super super fancy camera so if the
quality is a little lower sorry about
that but
that's where we are my shirt it's a
stray kid's shirt i went to their
concert on uh
sunday and this is and i got it there i
loved it so much i had to buy it
um i yeah
ali
i don't i don't know if they're gonna
i don't know if they're gonna introduce
the terrigen mist
i i just don't think
i just don't think they will
i really don't
so an apartment tour we could do that
maybe the next live stream i don't have
everything really set up right now i
can't really move this camera it's kind
of in place in my tripod um but i can
use a different camera next time and
and yeah i could show you uh
it's small um so for those who know greg
about the real rejects um he bought a
house and he has a back house
like a guest house and uh basically i i
rent that from him i moved in to that so
yeah yeah uh sue i'm in la so rocket and
kyrie aren't here sadly
but uh they will be back next live
stream hopefully if i'm in uh
in my actual home that i that i own this
is just a place that i rent in uh la
right now so i can
work with studios and do stuff like that
you know
so i'm here i'm here this week i've been
here for a little bit sometime
now uh
go back soon
yeah i you know the terrigan miss like
i don't think it's that the humans
aren't or that the inhumans aren't that
interesting because
i'm i mean yeah their show was
it did it wasn't successful
but that doesn't mean that they won't be
successful successful wow speak much
successful in the mcu
billy bug news what up man
uh i'm thinking carol danvers on the
post-credits scene
is uh that's what i'm thinking hey my
gosh so john thank you so much love you
all love you all
oh thank you bunga vr i hope you have a
great day uh slash knight as well oh
lucky trailer two oh we're not getting
that for a while they haven't even they
just started filming loki uh season two
yeah so
jeff gambit y'all albert i am
i don't know i don't there's a lot of f
words that could be
uh
hey
for just
limit shane i i'm so sorry i did my best
to pronounce that but thank you so much
big time a long time fan long time fan
uh sue yes my uh
my brother
uh lives with me in my house uh
back home and he is there watching over
over my cats keeping them company yeah
so uh
they're they're in good hands
they're in good hands
uh
you know i would really love to see
who asked this advent i think advent
catacar
uh i i would i would like to think that
we're gonna see the scrolls tonight i
really oh i haven't checked
my youtube uh i i would love to see
our
i would love to see our
or our i keep saying art i would love to
see the cree
i mean
it just makes sense we've already seen
the blue arm that's like connected to
the uh the bengal
clancy i see you texting me i
can't read it right now
um
yeah i would love to see the scr the
creep pop up i don't think we'll see the
scroll
unless it's like a dodc or the scroll
kind of thing
um
jake hedge what's up what's up oh is uh
is chris not live
you know what why don't we give
christopher a call
just to make sure he's awake
thank you jake appreciate that oh kane
fam 12 thanks for the oh it says message
retracted but thanks for the super chat
let's call chris
are you awake
oh there you go
i got p i got people in my chat asking
where you're at bro
you can thank jake hedge for that he
sent me a super chat was like where's
chris i was like let me call him
there you go jake
fairly well
albert i don't know what you're uh
oh don't call will don't call well well
sleeping
was like three hours ahead albert you
don't need to be sorry i just didn't
know what you meant
i didn't check
there we go okay
we gucci
everything seems to be working fine
right yes maybe no
why not
are you talking to me mr anderson
jake thank you no you uh you just saved
chris
right there
you shouldn't be saying thank you thank
you to me
or love you i should be saying love love
you to you chris should be saying that
that's what it should be chris should be
telling you that he loves you because uh
you're the one that got that i just kind
of uh i just kind of assumed that chris
was streaming uh
i kind of just checked the settings on
my youtube you know just to make sure
everything's functioning right and then
after that you know
uh
i kind of just go live and do my thing
and re read the comments so today like
my computer's over here and when i'm in
my home
um
and i'm in my home studio like my you
know my setup and stuff the camera sits
in like right above the tv so like i
read the chat here chat's over here so
if you see me
looking over here i think you guys could
figure it out uh
which movie is in your background that
that is a black pink uh cover of the
rolling stones because blackpink is one
of my favorite groups ever this is a
stray kids
box for a light stick this is a stray
kids shirt
i haven't had a chance to set up my la
place yet i do have this that i got at
the world premiere of the
light year
it's like
where there's a button somewhere that
like that lights up
it's like
i want to say like
it's almost like the infinity gauntlet
like it's the same casting that they
used for it it's supposed to be like a
drink holder
does it fit this
yeah boy
what up
anyways that's what it is so i i haven't
had a chance to like set everything up
yet
i'm gonna put you
back up here
hey king fam two no twelve sorry the my
the mouse was covering the one
sorry the message yeah i was uh
wondering about that this episode better
be an hour long you go to san diego
comic-con you know um i really wanna go
to san diego comic-con unfortunately i
think i have to stay
because i have to cover it you know what
i mean um i have to do videos about like
everything that's going to be happening
so if i go i can't really cover it but
i've got invited
um
you know as like a press
as press to cover it i i want to go i
just think um
i just think
i just think i'm gonna be
staying here to to cover it uh people
ask him what i'm drinking it's just uh
crystal light
just crystal like in a package
i don't have any water bottles and i i
just have these plastic cups so it's
just crystalline
dude idiot sue it is i'm because it's
from disney light years from disney i'm
pretty sure they had like all these
already made and they just use the same
gauntlet
for sure
oh uh some guys are
are asking
about getting timed out guys if you spam
mr anderson's going to get you
you got to watch that we try to we try
to keep the spamming at a minimum in our
uh in our chat or chat here uh what time
it's 11 43 i should get disney plus
pulled up here
disney not disney.com disneyplus.com
oh please don't i have my
i have my mo oh no i'm still logged in
cool because i have my mobile compute
like the computer i take with me when i
like travel and stuff
sometimes it makes you
log in
and i i'm like the worst with like
remembering passwords and stuff like
that i am i am the worst
all right not out yet
louis berry hope credit scene is young
avengers set up kate oh man louis you've
got high expectations buddy um
which i like i like optimism but i'm
worried that you're gonna be
disappointed
i don't think we're gonna get much from
this episode i think comrade's gonna be
the enemy
even though he wasn't set up that way i
just
i've thought about this i don't
i don't think the dodc should be the
enemy because it's like they were kind
of in the show
but like
unless unless
aim and less aim
is behind the dodc which i actually
think
but i don't think it's going to be
revealed in this episode but that would
be like the only way
the dodc being the main final villain of
the show would make sense if it was aim
and modoc behind
uh
the dodc but i don't think so so i think
comron is going to be the villain
yeah
uh is comer possessed uh
it's a possibility i thought about that
i did think about that um
his you know his mother sending
whatever
power
she had to him
could have possessed him in some
in some way shape or form you know so uh
yeah
you know what i i i would like to know
um i would i would like to know in the
chat please
uh what did everyone think of thor love
and thunder we're not going to talk
about spoilers
i just want to know if you thought it
was a good movie or not i i loved it
i really did love the movie i
i really did love the movie i i've seen
i've seen quite a bit of people say that
it wasn't a good movie and i see some
youtubers
say that wasn't a good movie i'm sorry i
thought it was a great movie
i
laughed so much and i also cried it was
emotional and like i thought the story
was good yeah the ending i'm not gonna
no spoilers there's no spoilers but
maybe like a little rushed like maybe a
little bit rushed but you know that
doesn't
i can see how sometimes it kills a movie
for some people but
but yeah it was all right it's all right
best door to come out see that's what
see this is this is
this is what i'm hearing so many people
like i love the movie i loved it it was
awesome best thor movie ever then some
people were like ah it sucked
wouldn't watch it again it was horrible
mediocre but yeah you know i mean
i'm trying to read but the comments
coming in so fast
uh guide the chair do i still play
fortnite funny
that you asked that
because lately all i've just been
playing like league of legends a lot but
the other night me and my buddies were
playing and we're like yeah let's play
fortnite we haven't played it in a long
time and uh we played and i miss it so
um
i i
i really i really really liked it
cane fam you you thought it started off
slow really i thought the the opening
was pretty good granted yeah there was
some it got a little slow
but i thought the the opening with gore
was really good and then i thought the
opening scene with the guardians was
really good i thought that started off
really good really funny when he does
the splits i was just cracking up
i
did i spilled something no i i was just
i was cracking up
but yeah no no it definitely escalates i
i'm with you there and that does
i think it should have been longer
and i just read
that was a rumor nothing confirmed but i
just read like
uh marvel
was like pushing taika or somebody to
make you know to make a movie that was
you know shorter i don't know how true
that is
um
what
uh can i ah everything's moving so fast
uh yeah mr anderson i i can always see
yours um
gore is amazing a really deep villain
for once you know
no no spoilers no no spoilers so
i thought he was amazing i thought it
was one of the best marvel villains
sue most of the koreans say it was
difficult to understand the jokes in it
oh
dang there's that language barrier huh
that's unfortunate well what did what
did you think yourself did you have a
cause your english is great we you know
we talk
and um
i'm curious
what you thought about that
asean akram yes it is
here uh i so i
i personally really love taika
um
i i really really really love taika and
here hold on
i really love his style
is it out yet sorry i just gotta check
this out yet
i love tyka style and like honestly i
was expecting exactly what i saw and
since i enjoy his sense of humor i
didn't mind that all the jokes
um
yeah like at all
um
oh so can you explain aim uh
advanced idea
mechanics
uh basically like an organization
like through technology and stuff is
like
basically wants to overthrow like the
government pretty much
um
they give like weapons to like
radicalists and stuff like that um
and if you know modok
he is uh
typically be behind
them
i lost where did there we go
i hope
to get the four hour cut and the taylor
cut
what's the taylor cut
am i missing something
uh
i don't know
if taiko within actually came out and
said like about the deleted episodes and
and
like a director's cut and stuff like
that and he like straight up said like
nope the deleted scenes weren't in the
movie i'm not showing them any straight
up said like no there's no director's
cut like
he actually said some directors like do
need to be
i don't remember the exact words like
it wasn't like i don't think he said
kept in check but it was basically
something like that
ryan shaw thanks for the super chat
what's up warren what's up brian what
are you expecting from this episode um
honestly i think i'm expecting some
pretty simple stuff i think comrade's
gonna be the the villain
um
i'm hoping
kamala and bruno show some type of
romantic something like with a kiss or
something like that and then i think in
a post-credits scene captain marvel is
going to show up right like at the very
end of this episode captain marvel was
going to show up that's that's all i'll
say all i'm expecting
there's going to be a fight
and the dodc's not going to figure out
who kamala is or if or if they do
they're going to be like ah she's good
who cares so i'm hoping the post credit
scene isn't just freaking of the dodc i
hope it's of captain marvel um
or the marvels
how cool would it be if they showed us
uh a trailer for the marvels not gonna
happen don't think that
but yeah that's that's kind of all i'm
expecting all right it's out
i i since i'm in a different setup i
can't uh i can't do the timer
but we're just gonna go ahead and start
it and uh we're like
we're just gonna start it at five
four
three
two
one it's 15 minutes long and it's called
no normal
all right here we go
wait a second
oh no
oh crap
i have to watch it on my phone
i have to watch it on my phone because
it's it's blocked it's like since i'm
streaming it's not letting me view it
dang
that's unfortunate
since it since i'm streaming it's just a
black screen crap i'm gonna have to
watch on my phone
[Laughter]
yeah wow disney is like i'm not even
showing it and they're blocking it on
this wow
yeah i'm not i'm not even streaming yet
they're blocking it here geez
so i just have to watch it on my phone
now
that's that's that's what we're gonna do
because i don't have a dual pc set up
here so it makes it really tough
jeez
i don't know where else to go because
i'm the bad guy
all right here we go
i'm just gonna watch on my phone i got
subtitles on
kids
wait can you guys hear the sound can you
hear it you shouldn't be able to hear it
you should be good now right i'm muting
it like in between me talking
all right so it should be good now
because i'm muting my mic in between me
talking
oh is she gonna tell her family
yeah she's going to tell a family
what up wig
[Laughter]
dude
speaker speaker was the problem
so glad she told
they're supportive
look at that
what's up todd lamb
welcome welcome welcome yeah we're
watching right now guys i'm
unfortunately have to watch it on my
phone because uh
i'm streaming on my computer so i can't
watch it on my computer apparently
glee archfox you see that huh
wait a second no way no no no no is it
her mom
is it her mom that gives her the outfit
is like an ancient
look at that
marcus with great light comes great
nightlight
oh is she just straight up
flying now oh no she's running
hey look at that that's pretty good
she stopped for the red light when she
was running over the traffic makes sense
yeah big improvement
i know she stops the red light as she's
going over the track i'm also kind of
confused like i feel like she can
make stuff and like make the move rather
than her running she's still like
running she still has to do like
exercise
it's marveling time miss marvel in time
is what she should say
ensure your safety my butt
you can't just tell people your secret
ingredients
also why do they think it's a guy
she literally has long hair
but then again so does mr anderson
ah
she's totally trolling oh
is that the dude from the beginning
i don't know that is
yo they got secret storages
yeah perfect perfect disguise it's half
of the marvel this guy they just need
the sunglasses
yes there is an episode six this is a
finale
and she has found them
nice it only took the finale to give us
the actual costume but it looks great
yeah she cares about bruno not this
other stupid guy oh
oh no
oh no
what is happening
oh mr anderson you might be right
possession might be a thing
i i think yeah i think it's definitely
oh thank you alexis parra
um i definitely think he is like his
mother
his crap
his mother is like
possessing him somehow
oh you know somebody can get him out of
town i'm like what is he gonna do he's
in freaking pakistan
across the world but he knows someone
gotcha
oh it's not here
nice stitching
yes she's mad at you you didn't tell her
we have started we're at uh
13 minutes 45 seconds and yes i have
seen ob1 i loved it
we're currently watching it y'all
i have to watch it on my phone cause
it's blocked on my computer
because i'm streaming
yeah camaron is trying to be good it's
definitely going to be some type of
possession thing that uh
that uh that like takes him over
she also is kind of the reason that your
life was in jeopardy though but yeah
didn't i think we'd see her again in all
honesty
that bros there
mad scientist dude i wonder what that is
into my resting
okay they're gonna make some clouds or
something
you're doing great zoe you're doing
great
i was actually missing the like
animation kind of designs that they were
doing in the first few episodes
it's always real planned
what's up coach sean
those non-lethal guns look pretty lethal
they're not leaving a trail of
destruction you guys are the ones that
are blowing stuff up
will she
listen
will she listen
she can say yes or no yes or no
no
what a stupid hoe
not cousin cameron
do you even like british bake off
diver sucks
and she's getting fired
all right come in softball plan go go
ah
disco bomb
nice nice
music is great
i hope everyone in the dodc gets fired
for being so bad
dang this music is great
okay that may be non-lethal but it still
looks like it hurts
it feels like uh home alone now
with all the traps
that's what i'm saying mr anderson these
kids are like making that they all
deserve to be fight no don't get tight
with comrade you're supposed to be with
bruno
yeah i mean devers lied and said that
the k they were causing
they're holding what
i don't like that
don't like that at all
i don't i like it yes good
the real mvp
oh yes drive
i'll have to look into that after this
take a look
oh bruno's are the best bruno is the
best
oh
dang day day
ah there we go i see what they're doing
okay okay okay
it's working
oh need your mother huh
it's getting a little interesting now
gross
how are these non-lethal weapons
finally
i like this
bring our guys in are there other guys
not already i'm confused
and there he is no disguise no nothing
he's about to just
mess him up
yo
that looks pretty good
are you serious
whoa
that's that's a that looks lethal
those are those are those are big
weapons
uh more like the drdc woke up and chose
violence what the hell
yeah is captain marvel about to show up
okay
oh
oh we're gonna see it are we gonna see
some miss marvel action
finally
okay okay okay
whoa
his mom didn't have these powers i'm
very confused
nice catch
it's about time we saw some of the
actual like enlargement stuff
nice nice noise
oh no
dude this girl's the worst
oh that's something
what is he trying to to do oh that's
kind of cool
oh that's tight
y'all should move i'm just throwing that
out there come on
could be a superhero
did she just
okay
okay i like it
oh they're gonna think
i think she killed him
oh all the people oh it's gonna be cool
it is the name of the episode no normal
oh that's cool i like this a lot oh i
really like this
cut peace
what quote marcus
then you attacked a bunch of kids
i really hope that means you're fired
my girlfriend
obviously batman's in the post credits
obviously
bro i love this song
i love the song so much
this is literally on my gym playlist
it's called indian summer is the name of
it i just remembered it love it
i'm still figuring it out
ah kamala means perfect in arabic ah
that's
that's cute
but nerdy it's like wonder marvel
kamal means marvel
i share the same name as carol freaking
danvers
and
there it is
nobody notice
it's like
no one notices that she comes out of
that house
you know what i'm saying
oh snap oh snap oh snap
we really bonded in that explosion
whoa no they did not just say that oh
yo
shawarma
yo they actually said that
interesting
very interesting implications
guys i'm uh if you're trying to avoid
spoilers i would i would leave because
it looks like everybody's uh gonna be
talking about but wait is this post
credit
no not yet is there a post credit we
shall find out oh wait there there's
kind of a there's kind of a post credit
hold on hold on
is it worth it
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
ah that's funny
okay okay okay okay
so one post credit scene
is there another does anybody know
just one post credit
just one post credit okay
okay okay okay
all right um
let me go back and look at something
okay we're about to talk about spoilers
okay she does seem to be wearing
something on her left wrist but is she
wearing it on her
right one as well
i can't tell
it definitely has a better look
uh she kind of is wearing it on the
other side
i'll have to like
uh
dang it
go back 10 seconds
stop now girl back i just missed it yes
stupid
is she wearing something on the other
side
kind of uh
kind of okay wow okay uh
people's people people keep saying the
x-men theme came out like the theme song
where was that at because i don't
remember that
interesting i think uh
yeah i i didn't hear the x-men theme
my mic is cracking
i don't know how to fix that
is it better
cosmic nerd thanks for super chat no i
didn't i i didn't is uh
let me let me go back and
hear it hold on
like a mutation
oh
[Music]
oh
oh
yeah let's uh
go to youtube
i didn't catch that
so
x-men
theme 97
let's
you yo
dude that oh my gosh it is it no it is
it
that that literally is it
wow
dude that really was
okay so that's like confirmed
yo
that is confirmed
that is crazy yeah no that totally is it
wow
dude that no that is it
wow
oh jeff thank you yes oh my gosh that is
literally it
wow
okay hold on i gotta i gotta get crit
wow
that's amazing
that's crazy
all right well there you go i'm
expecting big thing i'm expecting really
big things from uh
from san diego comic-con now
wow
okay that's pretty freaking amazing
i don't have discord on this computer
chris
so they confirmed the x-men and even
played the x-men theme song
yeah no i i heard it and i you can
oh for sure 100 percent
yeah just search uh like x-men uh
opening theme
animated series and you'll hear it
why can't i get the discord
they can't hear me
no you're on my phone on speakerphone
hey everybody hey hold on
let me see if i can
so stupid discord's being so stupid
i know you can't hear chris sue hold on
let me
yeah it was definitely like a synth
synth version you know
blah blah blah
strife explain what's happening read
last don't know
i got just got chills hearing that that
is it is that what you're referring to
uh yeah so when bruno says mutation it
plays the theme
of
the x-men from the animated series
so basically yeah like bruno discovered
mutants and oh man so
yeah
so like are they
i'm confused like
well
right so
how are there
i'm just kind of wondering like have no
have no mutants been discovered yet or
are have they been discovered
and
you know
they just haven't talked about them yet
you know
yeah um
okay that's the that's the biggest part
to me like yeah the postcard i i called
the post credit scene i i
yeah
i i called the post credit scene like i
was like if there's gonna be any type of
captain marvel
anything it's gonna be in the post
credits scene of the finale like i knew
it like i knew she wasn't just going to
show up at the end and like save the day
so
maybe probably i mean it kind of seems
like that
yeah
yeah i'm kind of curious to see
i i the only reason i'm like really
hesitant to say like they're gonna fuse
the the mutants and the inhumans like
together is because we did see black
bolt in
uh
i think so no did they not i don't
remember
they not say
black agar maltigon king of the inhumans
king did it not say king of the inhumans
i mean maybe i
hold on i think i might have figured out
discord
they did
that's what i thought i thought they
said blocker baltigon king of the
inhumans
so yeah the inhuman king is what my chat
is saying that's what i thought
hey thanks happy appreciate that uh
appreciate that super chat yeah no
normal
yeah i love the content bro keep it up
thank you so much
yeah um
there you go
keep keeper of the
terrigan mist huh
into my resting
all right let's see if i can look
see if i can get in here
i'm sure it just won't let me in super
easily because why would it do that
maybe
hold on maybe i'm not a robot
okay wait oh this is not
oh this is not the right i did not sign
it to the right account
oh how do i sign out
how do you sign out of discord
yeah
wow i can't believe they pretty they
pretty much just like
confirmed the mutants
i mean they really did
like pl like same mutation
like yes
inhumans have like a mutation as well
but that main thing is you know
the whole thing is like it's activated
by the terrigan mist and like
i don't know i don't i don't typically
like when you hear mutation you think
mutants you don't think in humans
yeah he specifically said we didn't even
have time to talk about mutants like
kevin feige specifically said that at
sdcc 2019 like that has to mean
mutants is the x-men yeah and he he did
clarify that like immediately after
somebody asked him in an interview and
he was like oh mutants is x-men they're
interchangeable
that is pretty crazy i mean he just
he just confirmed it
all right something wrong with you like
yeah no he straight up said
in like he straight up said mutation
like
that's crazy
that's crazy well it's asking me to to
verify my account but i don't have an
email somewhere
nice
that's pretty crazy yeah that's uh that
one that one's uh
that that that is it i mean
that was it so okay we can't talk about
the post-credits scene uh
if you're avoiding spoilers
leave
[Music]
or if you don't care
uh yeah um okay heroes playbook what's
going on
um
glad to talk to you in the live stream
not just on twitter coincidence
mutations are mentioned today before
comic con i think not again bro you're
one of my biggest motivators thanks so
much man uh
you know hall h i i did get you know i
can go as press
i'm not gonna go i'm gonna sit at home
and wait for the news so i could do
videos on
it to be perfectly honest i'd rather
i'd rather make videos about what's
happening yeah it would be super super
cool but like uh
yeah i just i i think it'd just be more
beneficial for me to to you know to work
um
anime dimensions just saw the movie they
said black bolt the gun keeper of target
missed inhuman king these are the exact
words thank you so much yeah i thought
they did mention he was the inhuman king
i don't believe they said professor
xavier was an x-men
i don't think they said that
because they said
they said uh
captain carter first avenger right
um
did they say
they didn't call they didn't say
fantastic four for reed richards they
just said he was the smartest man alive
right
yeah
i mean we could look up the scene it's
all you know it's freaking somewhere
online
right right yeah
well
no so i'm really okay so
let's talk about that second post or the
for the post credits only one sorry it's
about the post credit scene so
again i i definitely think it's the
the bengal is related to the creed they
found it
on a blue arm which is cree
right and and if it that means it's
probably the the nega band and the mega
band there's two there's two nega bands
i'm assuming
captain marvel might have been
in contact with the other one she did
appear to have something on her wrists
it looks like they're on both of her
wrists though it could maybe they split
one bangle at two something like that it
definitely looked like she had something
on her wrist and um
yeah i thought i saw it on the right
side too
um
my child is saying some some they are
saying smartest man alive read riches of
the fantastic four cool cool cool cool
well you know what i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna go do this let's gonna look
it up i know it's online somewhere
let's let's find out exactly what they
say
uh
multiverse of madness
illuminati scene
there's no way this is the actual scene
this looks to be way too good of quality
oh this is the scarlet witch versus the
illuminati
the first avenger
poltergon
the inhuman king
reed richards of the fantastic four love
it ah that was such a cool scene it's a
shame they
all died
yeah she just says captain marvel
defender of the cosmos so anyways yeah
um
the
the bengal has another there's another
bangle like i think they're the mega
bands
and i think
captain marvel maybe came in contact
with the other one
and powers got interchanged what
right right right now the this is
actually used in the comics um
i think
uh oh hold on lone wolf thanks for super
chat uh is sdcc streaming marvel paint
alive i did out it
um also people saying that she
shape-shifted i don't think that's the
case cara looked confused when seeing
the pose of herself yeah no she
definitely needed shape-shift so this
uh this actually happens in the comics
um let me i can't remember if it's
marvel
i think it is marvel i don't remember
it's marvel or yonrog
crap hold on
uh
but they but they switch uh they
actually use these in the comics where
it could be it might be captain marvel
yeah the nega bands trapped marvel in
the negative zone
and he was a and rick rick jones was
able to switch places with him
um
because rick jones found a pair of mega
bands on earth
and they allowed him to switch places so
i'm assuming that that miss marvel has
one band uh carol danvids had the other
one
and that's what
they switched
because that's kind of been done in the
comics yeah
that's that's what i yeah so i
definitely think carol was in contact
with the other band somehow whether she
was wearing a different type of bin
on her i i would assume they would be
identical
but um
but you just don't know maybe they maybe
the other one was you know modified in
some way shape or form they're they're
ancient cree relics like ancient like i
i believe in the comics they're like a
millennia old like they're super old so
you know
they could have
it could have definitely been altered
like physically right and the cree could
have you know taken one and
turned it into a different type of
weapon but i think for sure captain
marvel somehow came in contact with one
miss marvel with the other
maybe something was activated on both of
them and then bam they switched spots
but i knew this was going to happen i
knew it was going to happen because i
they have to lead into
you know
the marvels
they had to and i just i just i
definitely
knew that captain marvel wasn't going to
show up in the actual episode
i
want to know what's going to happen
at sdcc
so i mean basically you know what
happened was
in my mind this is like
what happens is oh
wait a second could that have been
related to the shang chi post credit
scene where she gets like a signal and
she has to go could something have been
happening
with
maybe the bengal like maybe they've had
the bengal and and it hadn't really been
activated in a while and all of a sudden
it's getting activated and she goes by
it and she gets transported
because kevin feige said everything was
going to start to connect soon and
everything would kind of be revealed
soon
and
right and yeah you know this big
right yeah this big thing
this big thing before sdcc right like
i mean you know that's planned like
perfectly planned right i mean
[Laughter]
like
it's perfectly planned like the ending
right before you know san diego comic
con comes out i mean
they don't do a lot by accident or or
coincidence you know what i'm saying
yeah you know i
i really think
i really think
hey i said it's marvel in time no i said
that during the live stream at some
point i'm watching the episode i said
it's marvel in time
um
i'm sure someone said it before me but
yeah um
i this is
i think this is i think that that's like
enough that's confirmed to me the x-men
are confirmed they played the theme song
from the 97 animation show
right it's a little bit too much of a
coincidence that this is the the final
thing that we'll really see from marvel
before going into sdcc like it's
literally the last thing we're gonna see
and
and the last thing literally like the
last thing that kevin feige said at the
last sdcc which was 2019 because
pandemic the literal last thing that he
said was we didn't have time to talk
about the mutants
that's the literal last thing he said
and now
shut up
[Laughter]
okay one of the last things he said
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's that
hmm
yeah i'll have to you looked it up
yeah it's interesting yeah i still i
still well
but but but why don't you look up the
post credit scenes
for
what was the post credit scene
was it the post credit scene of captain
marvel where she shows up to the
avengers and she's like where's fury
what what is her hairstyle like then
oh well i guess in the beginning of the
movie it is longing down too i was going
to say because if it's not short
oh i okay so the hair is the same but
the suit's different well you never
really know what could happen in between
yeah i think i think that that might
yeah i think that might not matter
wait and see lackey one
while the mutant reveal is cool it
doesn't negate the fact that miss marvel
is the weakest of disney plush shows in
terms of writing the storyline thoughts
um it wasn't my least favorite but it
definitely was not
in my top
disney plus shows uh i think the finale
was better than the last few episodes
that we got best episode was probably
the first or third
uh
i had a problem with the writing
yeah i like miss marvel i like the
character
yeah that's a great like that's how i
would describe it the writing was
yeah
the show was
it was okay
but i loved the character
right unfortunately the story i think
was kind of weak
yeah there wasn't
yeah this is this is this is really
and look you know if you like did i see
some people
saying that they really liked the finale
and that's good i definitely think this
finale was uh
as far as like an episode
is uh
what
yeah yeah
what
yeah it wasn't a super huge finale but
it set stuff up and it gave us her
origin story and it finished that but
yeah i do agree that the writing
was not very good
it was uh
it wasn't the best um
i was a little disappointed
with def definitely disappointed with
the ending like
the first three episodes were better
than the last three
yeah
yeah louis berry yeah iman is a great
kamala khan and i really love the
character i wish it had better
storytelling behind it
so
oh of course yeah i think you know the
young avengers have been set up
are being set up and you know i think
that's just
right yeah that was that was a big that
was a big
thing
um
so yeah i mean geez they set up the
freaking
mutants like they're they set up the
muses like they're they really really
did like they literally played the
the 97 x-men theme song
as
freaking like that's great as they said
mutation they literally played the theme
song like literally
that's insane
and yeah in the post-credits scene i'm
definitely thinking i definitely think
that
it's totally there's another band out
there and that's how it got swapped
because in the comics the mega bands um
captain marvel not captain marvel
captain marvel gets trapped in the
negative zone and uh rick jones finds a
nega bands on earth because there are
multiple
mega bands um
he finds him on earth and then
he switches with him
so i'm definitely thinking you know
i'm definitely thinking that's exactly
what happened like kind of like a play
off of that so
dang i mean
dang they said the mutants and uh
i think i think they established that
that those were are indeed the mega
bands
i i yeah
i think that's just i think that's
exactly what happened
yeah so i don't know how people are
going to uh
i don't really know what they're going
to think of that i don't know how people
are going to react to miss marvel kind
of being a mutant instead of you know
her being an inhuman i guess they are
kind of
abandoning
the whole inhuman i hate to say that
because i know there are some big and
human fans out there um especially like
comic book inhuman fans um
oh man
it's definitely mutants though like that
the theme played i let's do it a few
times like the theme played
so yeah i think that's the i think
that's uh that's a weak point of the
finale is now people are saying then
who's the main villain of the show
is it the dodc was it comrade because he
wasn't really a villain the clandestines
kind of like their story really
i i'm sorry i thought it's bad writing i
just
miss marvel herself is a really cool
character iman is really great at
playing her i look forward to seeing her
a lot more
um
yeah i mean but i i do think it's you
know it's bad writing
right you see john ramos that's why he
specifically said the comic book fans
because um
um
the show
it's like hit and miss with people right
and it was
technically a failure because you know
got cancelled and everything like that
so it's like
inhumans are fantastic in the comics but
uh
i don't know but i
i don't know like
should they combine the inhumans in the
x-men i just i
i don't know
yeah i don't really know i guess
i guess the dodc was the the final
villains at the end i
uh oh
man i'm tired this one i guess the dodc
was a villains um
but
yeah
okay well that was it that was uh
that was something uh
having them all be x-men is fine yeah
i'm seeing a lot of
comments yeah and yeah the damage
control was bad devers was um
she sucked
she sucked and i almost think
that
i need i almost think that she's working
for somebody else than the you know her
bosses right secretly modoc maybe
i'm not letting that go oh hi chris
what happened did we lose you i can't
hear you
hello
oh hold on
hello
oh now i hear ya
no you haven't
[Laughter]
imagine a time because i think something
a lot of fans are struggling with right
now
the depth and maybe even the word
relevance of these shows
imagine they completely just cut episode
five
move this episode back
to episode five the finale and then
episode six is like
a preview into miss marvel and we
actually get like these connections with
some like the bigger characters and some
of the bigger story plots of the mcu as
well would have been a hell of a lot
better tell you that right so imagine if
we actually do start getting some of
those with these disney plus shows like
disney plus is new we've talked about
this there's a lot that they're still
learning about disney plus and and how
to use it to the advantage of
the bigger mcu i think that'd be really
cool like okay here's miss marvel's
origin story we're done at episode five
here's captain marvel let's do an
episode with them together and that can
be a massive cliffhanger for the movie i
would love that i would love that they
did that i mean
yeah
greg you're funny real rejects in the
chat
honestly chris you should pitch that to
[ __ ]
i'm gonna call him right now send him a
name or
that should be that should be what
happens because i think
i do think people want a little bit more
from the disney plush shows
i agree
and it's still new like you said um
this this though i mean holy crap they
said mutants there's a mutation and they
played the theme song like that's pretty
big
that's that's that's pretty freaking big
i mean
yeah
oh no there were some pretty big like
connections and stuff i just think
seeing the actual characters interacting
on disney plus would be
yeah it would be better
and the way you look at it is like from
thor love and thunder like the guardians
weren't in it very much
but the little they were in it has me so
excited for guardians of the galaxy oh
for sure oh for sure so if you can do
that with disney plus shows like hey
let's conclude the story and then kind
of build it over into something else
leaving it on a little bit of a
cliffhanger giving them a taste of what
captain marvel and miss marvel together
would be like beyond just her being in
it for 20 seconds
that i think would help
make more money yeah generate more
excitement yeah the universe a little
bit more i hope i hope down the road we
get to see a little bit more of that i
hope they tease a little bit more too i
think it would be beneficial for them a
lot
louis berry thanks for super chat loki
is still the best excited to see she
hulk yeah i agree i think loki is still
the best and i hope she hulk is good too
um
well all right we have some work to do
um
i didn't hate the show i think it was as
the kids call it now mid
[Laughter]
i think it was mid but i think the
character
miss marvel was awesome
yes i think amman is awesome i think the
character is awesome
um
i i definitely think for the inhuman
slash mutants
uh like what are they referring to i 100
it's mutants i they played the theme
song
so
okay
all right everybody we have some work to
do say goodbye to chris
in this makeshift final stream for miss
murph
um
yeah yeah yeah so all right bye chris we
love you
bye
so okay sorry this stream is uh
not in my normal location this is my la
place right now um
yeah yeah um
guys they said mutation and played the
theme song
from the x-men
animated series come on
that's big and that's what i'm about to
talk about right now and i'll break down
that post credit scene because if you
haven't heard me talk about it already i
definitely think it's uh
one mega ban connecting with the other
so
man
that's pretty that's pretty cool are
they getting rid of the inhumans
i think they might
i think they might mesh them together
because they don't know
the difference
right i
bruno doesn't know the difference he
just sees a mutation so he calls it a
mutation right that's what
you know we would probably say in real
life like oh your genes like they have a
certain mutation to them
and
she
can still be an inhuman but they might
call it a mutation they might introduce
the mutants and then later on be like oh
wait your genes are actually kind of
different like yours gonna have to be
activated by something mutants don't
have to be activated
they could do that right
so for those of you who really want
humans i wouldn't worry too much about
it i'm sure they'll come at some point
in time i mean black bolt was in
multiverse of bandus you know so
um
so yeah i mean
the show is
okay like it was okay miss marvel the
character is amazing i really like her a
lot but i think the best thing to come
from the show is bruno saying mutation
in all honesty um so the show's okay for
me
um
but i i do love kamala khan i love the
character
sue i'd love to see that too yeah guys i
see a few people saying this like i'd
love to see
i'd love to see x-men verse and humans
uh it'll be really cool
oh i'm tired
oh there's a
there's a
super chat hold on louis thanks for
another one hope for she-hulk matt
jessica luke dwayne johnson that's the
thing
william hurt general ross red ross they
filmed him before he passed away i mean
they could use cgi as well
uh
i i think marvel doesn't like to recast
um if with the exception of a roadie you
know from the first iron man
um ah man but that was so cool all right
everybody we're gonna stop super chats
because i'm about to get off um
it was a fun show it wasn't any it
wasn't super epic or anything like that
you're right mr anderson but it was fun
there were fun times um
i think it appealed to a younger
audience
and as an an older man who's not in high
school
and is out of college
uh i enjoyed the ride but it was it's
definitely ranks in the lower disney
plus shows for me for sure it doesn't
rank up with loki one of vision moon
knight you know it's better than what if
i don't think i'll ever dislike anything
as much as i disliked what if
so uh
yeah
tux i
i could agree with that i could say like
an eight out of ten like a seven out of
ten finale and like the show overall was
like a five six out of ten
yeah
i i can say that i can say that
but you know what if you like the show
i'm really happy for you i'm glad you
enjoyed this you know and if you're one
of those younger people and you
connected with the show that's awesome
that's i think that's what it was meant
for and if you're
any age and you enjoyed the show and
connected with it like that's that's
awesome you know every show is not going
to be for everybody um but i'm really
glad if it was for you i i hope you
found some joy out of watching the show
i hope everybody at least found
something you know
something they liked about the show and
if you didn't well
you know
sometimes it's a mess
you know but hey you know i guess they
since they're dropping so much content
now it can't all be you know home runs
uh but i think it did do a good job at
like giving us an origin story right the
story writing could have been a lot
better but
but yeah uh lewis berry thanks for super
chat hopefully this is the last one um
sam elliott as general ross they recast
hulk too oh they did recap cast
poke two obviously yeah
i just been after deaths right because
like chadwick bozeman they're saying
they're not gonna recast him so
maybe because william hurt died they
might not recast him but
if
if thunderbolt ross is going to be a big
character they they honestly should
recast him
um
yeah
yeah
so anyways all right guys got some work
to do
uh
gonna do pretty cool breakdown i have
cool thoughts and exciting thoughts
very cool and exciting thoughts so
um be sure to subscribe to the channel
if you have not yet uh thank you mr
andersen for being an awesome mod mr
anderson has his own channel as well um
and based on some instagram posts looks
like he's about to do some new videos
soon so you can
sub to him if you want uh more content
he's gonna post a link i'm sure
and uh
yeah we're i'm gonna end the stream now
i love you all so much love you on every
universe
uh it's morbid time
i feel like i should say that now at uh
in the streams but uh
bimbo thanks for really subscribing
thank you so much
appreciate it hope you continue to enjoy
the content um
i'll be back home my other home this is
my my rental in l.a but i'll be at my
actual home
uh
next week hopefully we'll do a live
stream just talking about everything and
uh i will see you guys next time i love
you all i really appreciate everybody
who joined in the chat who super chatted
and if you're just watching i appreciate
you just as much so uh thank you all
love you all catch next